wait only 33 seconds of two standard
logos and no cutesy transformation that
fits the movies pretentious animated
aesthetic should I give the movie credit
firts relative restraint guy I don't
care I have to send logos any logos
synchronized Sun rising seriously
supposes several species ourselves
simultaneously team up to whale on the
leaders in this jungle cuz those guys
pussies rule quit god dammit I said roll
credits already movie opens up with a
two-minute kid-friendly and fun musical
number followed by birds being cruelly
kidnapped from their homes how they do
these bird snatches snatch these birds
maybe you could get lucky throwing a net
and grabbing one but they were way up in
the air man this is the strangest Coen
Brothers homage I've ever seen I can't
even find the right eye scraper in this
scene why the hell's blue in this
enormous box by himself these smugglers
aren't just assholes they're also
incredibly inefficient hang on this is a
wooden box that's nailed shut but this
little girl was able to pry that open
with her bare hands
Jesus Midwesterners are tough as balls
they let her bring her bird to the
spelling bee championship and the final
word was cerulean if I were Ron de
Felice of Newtown I'd be screaming
home-field advantage to anyone who would
listen
oh sure she's super annoyed by the clock
sound but blues noises which are much
more abrasive are adorable I don't care
how much she loves this bird that's a
car alarm noise and that noise can go
right to hell I'm driving you back
thanks Linda bookstores yes mom I'd love
to visit who would take care of Blu fine
Linda loves her bird and all that jazz
but you're telling me she's never once
had him taken care of by someone else I
don't know how old she's supposed to be
but I'm guessing more than I'm capable
of finding someone to pet sit for me
while I'm away for a few days years old
along with four cookies which equals
five different items that can poison and
most likely kill you Burt jeez this
glass is stronger than the most tables
from game night also how the hell did
Tulio find blue it's not like he tracked
a black market sales record to a
collector in a metropolitan area Linda
accidentally Don to blue in the middle
of Minnesota
yes I introduced myself and shook my
tail feathers counterclockwise thus
deferring to his dominance I'd
not get that at all blue understands
English but not bird even though he was
clearly talking to the jokester birds
outside the bookstore just a second ago
of course that conversation was also in
English so animated movies for making me
figure out what exactly the
communication barriers are every time
please just call me Tulio I can call you
Betty Betty when you call me you can
call me yeah it's all arranged you will
be with him every step of the way and
instead of calling you in with this
information I flew all the way here from
Brazil to tell you in person because
that's not weird or stalker at all
how can a bookstore is this I know it's
a small-town shop but what respectable
business would have their product all
akimbo on the shelves it was very nice
of you to stop in and squawk around and
throw my bird man foreplay euphemisms in
Minnesota are weird
I have quad rated my vector angles what
the hell does Linda make of all this
when she sees the book propped up later
and all these Christmas lights set up
the poor woman probably thinks her place
is haunted by a ghost reader and this
probably had to go through years of
therapy I promised I would always look
out for you but what convinced Linda to
go to Rio she flatly refused to Leo's
offer and all we've seen since then is
blues failed attempt to flop considering
Linda never travels because she doesn't
understand the concept of pet-sitting
and say she doesn't have a passport
readily available for this jaunt to
another hemisphere come tomorrow night
everyone would be dressed like that not
me costume shadowing I'm a pop dad cage
open like a soda kid no one in the front
seat of this car notices this I'm their
great big mama bird you know I was gonna
make a comment that this dude is way
over the top but honestly have you ever
met a bird person don't worry I'm gonna
make you look irresistible man way too
much of the early part of this movie is
based on humans getting extremely
excited about bird cooking also why the
hell does Tulio have to do anything to
blue at all he's shown all gussied up
here but wouldn't his natural form be
more enticing is this why they're almost
extinct because they don't blow on a
bird bone wow that was fast that's also
a much better camera angle then they
should be getting right now like the
birds just fell out of a concrete but
the camera is perfectly positioned at
ground level to get this shot we should
probably give them some privacy what
this assholes had a massive mating boner
this entire movie but now that
supposedly going down he's gonna bail
this is like watching an entire porno
book
the money shot I wouldn't expect a pet
to understand yeah but I don't
understand how the hell Julie even knows
what a pet is she's been in the wild or
in this aviary her entire life so des
miss DISA tea should be as foreign to
her as French toast huh so to
orchestrate this abduction Nigel had to
get himself to the aviary by faking
injury the day before blue even arrived
but how would he know the blue was
coming in the first place
and once he got there how did he get
word to Fernando to say that the plan
needed to go down that night and exactly
right after one of the rare times that
two Leo's not in the lab goddamn I'm
more upset about this bull break-in than
anything else in this movie club drugs
that he reminds me of myself when I was
that age
and I was not prepared to watch an
animated version of City of God Nigel
alive okay up until now the movies
presuppose that humans and birds could
only communicate non-verbally
but suddenly Nigel understands the
necessity of keeping jewel alive because
a Brazilian dude told him that in
English do I have that wrong oh man I
bet Fernando's feeling pretty blue right
about now too soon oh if they're not
scared of Nigel why not just put the
food on a plate and let him come to it
yeah what's up with that there are
plenty of ways to show Nigel's a
dickhead but I'm getting this dark and
why would they even think about feeding
him poultry in the first place
I had it all the TV show women - Nigel
were this famous in Brazil - where there
was a television show about him how the
hell with Tulio not realise how he was
when he came to the aviary I mean we're
not talking about some Rando we just
happened upon a cockatoo this
motherfuckers obsessed with birds I'm a
feathery freak with a beak a bird meadow
right look I love Flight of the
Conchords and all their music I don't
need to see Jemaine Clements full rap
act in animated avian form that was
disturbing enough when he was the crab
in Moana no no kidding I thought we
established that way back in the aviary
scene not only are these makeshift zip
lines conveniently connected for escape
their pitch perfect for them to slide
down and not get stuck in the middle
like Jada pinkett-smith did in girls
trip
actually that's not true there have been
two other escape attempts where this
knowledge would have greatly influenced
Jules plant they are well let the record
show that this begins a chase where two
macaws that are chained to each other
outrun two grown-ass men I can show you
the town sparkly bumpy convenient sure
Nigel hit the one transformer that
controls the entirety of the electricity
in Rio de Janeiro also it's probably for
the best that he ended the game
unexpectedly it's not like anything else
exciting happens during a soccer match
you see leads flying birds birds and
he's flying
jool would be bird tastic at cinemasins
a night job oh yeah I remember that this
is all taking place in the span of one
day Lou and Linda arrived in Rio they
traveled through the middle of the city
during a Carnivale pregame did an entire
intake on the rarest bird on the planet
soon he immediately unsuccessfully made
it with the only other blue macaw was
abducted escaped and found their way to
this sanctuary I would have taken a week
minimum have you seen my bird if the
plan was to show the same flier to every
passerby why's Linda making this poor
bastard carry around all these copies
seriously they posted a flier not only
on the same wall but also right above
another flyer even if I knew where blue
was I'd be so annoyed by this over
posting that I'd sit on that information
you see scenes like this in movies a lot
man I'm just wondering how this actually
occurs I get sitting down for a second
to rest but how do you let yourself fall
asleep in that position and you're
telling me right around Carnivale when
an insane amount of people are in Rio
Linda and Tulio weren't robbed while
they were sleeping do you think I am an
idiot thing jesse eisenberg said to his
agent when being offered this script
somehow makes it into the script once
this chain is off I'm gonna go back to
being free in the jungle deal fine
yeah is it possible for two animated
animals to not have on-screen chemistry
because blue and you almost definitely
do not what's going on down there barely
antics that will help this movie gross
484 million dollars if this had been the
premise of the George Lopez show I might
have watched a few episodes
seriously this sequence of a mom and dad
toucan getting all horned up in front of
their kids has been going on for some
time I can't say that I'm totally not
into it but this is too much and this
movie just downshifted from City of God
to Slumdog Millionaire with no
also the is the point of stealing
wallets sure they like Chinese stuff to
play around with but they can't actually
use anything right are these assholes
using the tourists credit cards for
Amazon purchases from the Amazon just
for the sake of irony they're really
doubling down on making the fact that
blue can't fly an issue and it's by far
the least interesting part of the movie
you flap your right wing you flap your
left wing and together you fly this is
the Burning Man version of the Hokey
Pokey and when you feel the rhythm of
your heart it's like samba
but the Scorpions taught me that the
rhythm of love is the groove that hits
the bone maybe that's not relevant here
but the movie made me think about the
scorpions sauce in that I shot Cleary
Raphael is cuckoo for cocoa puffs wait
damn it movie I was actually getting
ready to praise you for showing
restraint on this cliched shot of the
Christ the Redeemer statue up until now
but you couldn't keep it in your pants
this is one sin that will not be
redeemed let's catch a right to the
waist and I know for sure that this
random truck is headed straight for Oh
I'm gonna chew through my own leg if
this doesn't come off soon geez Julie
purpley much I know the chain is
annoying and occasionally so was blue
this is much better than you had before
right you're on a goddamn adventure baby
gotta be every time then I have
convinced myself that this movie is
leaps and bounds ahead of the standard
animated fare the studio's out every
summer a line like this comes up to slap
me back to reality hottie and Ipanema
baby
I really wish this movie would declare
itself on whether or not it's a musical
if a musical were an erection this would
be a quarter job at best oh cool
looks like they're finally gonna do the
bird version of the matrix dance orgy
I'm not gonna play this song for fear of
dozens of angry birds attacking me
Hitchcock style but trust me the only
place you'll find Dumber lyrics is on a
Black Eyed Peas album this is senior
fight big nose
that's racist literally no humans will
be present to witness the massive noisy
monkey versus bird fight that's
occurring in the middle of a crowded
marketplace stunned the jewels I guess
it's a good thing that all these random
places where they end up being dropped
keeps them going in the direction of
Louise my you know I was thinking
between Fernando being an orphan with a
conscience Linda and Tulio finding love
monkey shenanigans Nigel statism
smugglers internal and external dynamic
Luiz and his drooling problem the merry
band accompanying the protagonist the
budding romance between jewel and blue
and the whole Carnivale influence there
are too many plot lines in this movie
the birds were here yeah sure they
worked in go to hell Tulio well part of
this character with telegraph that he'd
be such an immediately unbelieving dick
he came all this way to find the birds
man hey super slow-mo of a character
making a silly face and an animated kids
movie cliche yeah except for the whole
balance thing and the need for a
specific size that matches your upper
body strength and height and the manual
transmission you control with your foot
and yeah same thing why the is this
little still at the scene of the crime
the birds obviously won the fight and
nobody else stuck around whew I'm glad a
movie finally got back to its central
premise of the characters rooting for
some foul move down here just tell her
you have beautiful eyes that's good
great idea I guess Raphael sort of
whispering blue is at full volume so how
can you will not hear any or all of this
just tell her how you feel Jesus Christ
how does Raphael even know that I know
he wants to get these two together but
he's really got no background on their
relationship besides the fact that
they're chained together and from my
experience that's not the best way to
begin a relationship that's something
against dogs no but I have something
against animated drooled and I didn't
realize until just now are you sure this
is safe oh sure
despite being described as an adept
mechanic Luiz brandishes a welding mask
before we're using a table saw this is a
thing that happens the things of the
things to slip out of the other things
in other words this works I can't spend
my life walking around following you
wherever you're going hey it's not my
fault you can't fly man there's the
protagonist fight before the climax of
the movie cliche that I've been waiting
for also these two known each other less
than like 36 hours right but sure let's
have contrived romantic conflict because
kids totally love that every song sounds
exactly the same
Tiko tako ya-ya-ya Tiko tako ya-ya-ya
you are Juliet to his Romeo sure they
both die in the end but you get my point
I can by talking birds and schemee
monkeys and diabolical cockatoos all day
long but don't try and tell me this
indigenous Brazilian toucan knows the
narrative outcome of a king
Shakespearean tragedy going somewhere
pretty bad I am NOT saying that the
chances of an idol showing up right at
this moment are impossible I am saying
the chances of showing up at this moment
are impossible wow he just happened to
get a super rare blue macaw costume it's
like that movie knew they were coming
of course she's hot now I mean earlier
in the movie she had hair clips and
glasses and like a sweater it's
definitely the spit also a clucking good
timing Jeezy stupid puns can suck my
cock goddamn this movie is beautiful I'm
just gonna give it a sin for the parade
security allowing all these animals to
roam free in the thick of things but
these shots of Carnival have officially
made me go the other way dancers at the
Spearmint Rhino gentlemen's club would
beg to differ
just for Jenna get the bird you mean
live rarest and most expensive pair of
birds on the planet that you've waited
to load until the very end for some
reason this was the first movie script
to include the transcribed lyrics from
that annoying eiffel 65 song the birds
the fly don't need to wait for the hatch
to open all the way right it's already
plenty of room and carrying jewel easily
despite this being shown is impossible
earlier in the movie these birds are
roughly the same size but if anything
jewel is in much better shape but she
couldn't lift his ass this whole goddamn
time ah sudden Tom Cruise idiots um what
happened at the plane was abandoned just
offshore but we're supposed to assume it
crashed with no one noticing holy
did they adopt Fernando this is more
tough than the ending of face-off
wait so we have proof positive that
these two did finally copulate but we
don't get to see it on-screen come on
man we've been waiting for this moment
for the whole movie I feel like I've
been screwed more than jewel
[Music]
wait a minute this isn't my world just
support Linda this could be our last
chance I'll serve sex to see if you want
[Music]
good okay which leads me to my second
rule the double tap not pick a fight
with this person
target search of every gas station
residents
you'll never find him markinson's gone
there is I come in peace and you go in
pieces and maybe you're a penguin timber
Julie's not a penguin she's a lioness
you did not feel it in here thank you
for your honesty no coffin die this is
in your fight big nose don't you call my
husband big nose well I asked are big
nose little kinkow King Kong ain't got
horny